Second and lecture I was
reading last time from,
uh, uh, poems from the
30s, uh, those love poems.
Um, uh, lay your sleeping
head, my love and
this lunar beauty. Uh, the,
the ballad, uh, that I,
uh, read for you as I
walked out one evening. Uh,
also a poem about love a
also comes from the, uh,
later thirties. Uh, it is
collected though in this book, uh,
called another time a book,
odd and published in 1940.
Uh,
and I wanted to, well, let's
see. I'm afraid I've got
my order all mixed up here.
Um,
I wanted to show you what I'm [inaudible]
just the table of contents of this
book because it's, it has a
number of masterpieces in it, uh,
that you are reading.
Uh,
it's also significant that it's
organized in the way that it is.
The first section is called humbly,
I guess,
or practically, uh, people and places.
A edit includes a in it, um, the poem
I'll be discussing. Yeah. Shortly.
Museo de Boza. Uh, there's, um, uh,
another, uh, couple of sections,
a section called lighter poems,
uh, includes, um, uh,
well all kinds of, um,
song forms, a refugee blues, uh,
different kinds of blues and some, uh, uh,
kind of a gothic satirical ballads.
Uh,
Miss G, uh, James Honeymoon, um, uh,
poems that are antecedents for a
song like Maxwells silver hammer.
This is the kind of
thing Auden was riding a,
and then there's also something
else called occasional poems.
And in this box od and has
put Spain 1937, that, uh,
uh, great political poem,
uh, from the civil war.
Um, and, uh, these, uh,
palms that I'll be discussing today
and memory of WB Yeats and in memory of
Sigma Freud,
uh,
I wanted to call attention to
this, uh, uh, book. First of all,
because it shows us these poems embedded
in the actual context in which they
first appeared. Uh, but also to
point out the way in which Auden, uh,
has organized his, his book,
uh, that is to say has, um,
thought of his poems as belonging
to specific categories, uh,
and, and place them
accordingly. Uh, and they, uh,
they have different genres,
different forms,
suitable to different purposes in
occasions. And this is very much, um,
the, uh, uh, way in which od and
imagines himself as a poet, I think,
uh, that is, um,
someone I'm writing with a kind
of a technical mastery with,
uh, access, access to a whole
repertoire of traditional forms,
which are suitable to different
purposes and different occasions. Uh,
this general perspective on, um, uh,
on his work, uh, is related to, uh,
the topic that I introduced in, uh,
discussing as I walked out one evening.
And that is the whole
question of perspective, uh,
in on are you remember I talked
about how that poem seems to include,
well, at least three different, uh,
perspectives. That is the, um, uh,
quoted Song, uh, of the lover, uh,
who tells his beloved
that he will love her, um,
uh, until the end of time. Uh, then, uh,
there's the voice of the clocks who
speak from the point of view of time, uh,
and, uh, uh, correct.
Uh, his, his, uh, claims.
Uh,
and then finally there's a kind of a
narrative voice that seems to frame the
whole thing,
um,
with that image of the river running on,
uh, as in that poem, uh, odd and seems to
be able to incorporate in his poetry,
multiple perspectives,
each of which,
uh,
comment on or are framed or
conditioned by the others,
but each of which has its
independent truth. You could say.
Um, this is a topic that
we'll explore more today.
Looking at other poems. I wanted to
show you some, uh, photographs. Um,
in the, in the 1930s during the, um,
uh, Japanese, uh,
Chinese war, a prelude to
the Second World War, um,
on, uh, went with his friend
Christopher Isherwood, uh, to China,
uh, and created a book together
called journey to a war,
which includes Isherwood's pros
and Auden's, uh, poetry. Uh,
it's quite a remarkable book.
It also includes a photographs,
uh, which are presented
in an interesting way. Uh,
we have here, um, two
different photographs of boys,
uh, boys, uh, uh,
who are classified here
as soldiers. And, uh,
and then, uh, grimly, um,
uh, are identified, uh,
as with legs and without, uh, there's, um,
a kind of interest in these photographs
and in their presentation of how,
in the ways in which in war,
uh,
who we are is a matter of
perspective and point of view.
Um, the, um, um, war gave
a Auden an issue with, uh,
a opportunity to, um, uh,
experience what it is like
to be on the ground when, uh,
planes or overhead, uh, bombing
you. Um, and, and here's,
uh, here's one, a
photograph, uh, of that, uh,
condition, uh, in here
is, is another, uh, uh,
illustration of this general
point I wanted to make. There's a,
there are n a d unidentified
corpses, uh, under blankets.
There, uh, there are then, um,
uh, scattered human
remains and debris. Uh,
and the one photograph is identified
as the innocent and the other as the
guilty.
Well,
the great poem, uh, on
this general theme, uh,
in Auden's work is a music day. Boza. Uh,
it is a poem that
Auden wrote a after
returning from China, uh, in,
uh, December, uh, I believe, um,
1938,
ah,
contemplating a,
a,
a return to the United
States where he had, um, uh,
uh, visited, um, a short time before,
uh, contemplating in fact,
expatriation also contemplating,
uh,
an imminent war,
a world war that would,
uh, extend the, um,
horror that he had witnessed in China,
uh,
to all of Europe and beyond,
suffering in other words,
uh, was on his mind. And, uh,
it's the subject,
uh,
or rather arts relation to suffering
is the subject of this poem.
The poem, uh, has as its occasion, uh,
a visit to the museum. They
bazaar in Brussels, uh,
where um, odd and saw among
other works, uh, this painting,
uh, the fall of Icarus,
um, uh, that, um, uh,
is painted by Peter [inaudible].
Uh, this and other, uh,
Roy Eagles are referred
to in the course of, uh,
of the poem which precedes almost as a
kind of imaginary gallery tour or walk,
uh, in which, uh, Aaden,
uh, as our companion,
uh,
takes us to a different
works and contemplates their
commentary on the general
issue that, uh, he is,
uh, uh, raising here.
What is arts relation to
suffering about suffering?
They were never wrong.
The old masters,
how well they understood
it's human position.
He's concerned with how you
position suffering in human life
and use taking Roy goal
and, and uh, uh, as a,
as a model how it takes place while
someone else is eating or opening a window
or just walking Deli along as this line
of poetry itself seems to how when the
aged ar reverently passionately
waiting for the miraculous birth.
Now he's contemplating Nativity scene.
There must always be children who
did not specially want it to happen.
Skating on a pond at the edge of the wood.
Yeah.
They never forgot the old masters
that even the dreadful martyrdom.
And now he's looking at
[inaudible] painting the
massacre of the innocence that
even the dreadful martyrdom must
run its course anyhow in a corner.
Some untidy spot where the dogs go on
with their Doggie life and the torturers
horse.
Okay.
No more innocent or guilty than
those boys, I suppose. Scratches.
It's innocent behind on a tree.
The old masters, no, the human,
the human position of suffering,
it's positioned in human life.
Uh, position is important.
It's an important word for odd.
And here he's concerned with, uh,
how experiences placed.
Uh,
sometimes he calls this
geography. Uh, it is a, um,
uh, tote posts, a Motif, a,
an idea in his poetry that Elizabeth
Bishop will take over quite directly from
him, uh, and develop and
make central to her poetry.
The idea is that things
have meaning in relation to,
uh,
in their connection with,
but also their separation from each other.
Suffering is part, uh, but only a part,
not the center of human life.
A repertoire of actions and conditions
and states of being that is much larger,
uh, in, uh, um, embroil, uh,
in his massacre of the innocence. I
won't try to find it. Now, among my,
my slides for you,
uh,
odd and focuses on the
torturers horse, the, uh, uh,
the animal, uh, that is
a part of the scene, uh,
and that, uh, motivated by an Itch,
scratches, uh, it's, uh, behind, uh,
while the dreadful
martyrdom runs its course,
uh, in this poem, uh, as an
other, uh, uh, Auden poems,
a note, the pros, rhythms, uh,
the poem does seem to at
times walked Deli along,
uh, Auden like more is riding
in an expository manner,
I guess. Essayistic manner. Uh,
this is a part of the tone of the poem.
Uh, Auden is getting
into his poetry, uh, uh,
kind of neoclassical,
uh, 18th century, uh,
aesthetic, uh, uh, an ability
to talk about ideas, uh, in, in,
in poetry, uh, in, in, uh, again,
a discursive expository
manner that includes humor,
uh, and that, uh, uh,
is matter of fact is observant,
uh,
pain like the tiers that I talked about
last time that had dried on Auden's
pages. Uh, pain is part of the picture,
but it is just a part, it's
in a sense, been put aside,
all of this is a function of what
I'm calling Auden's perspectivism.
Uh, any scene borders on other scenes
where other people are positioned,
uh,
looking at the same thing differently
or not looking at it at all.
Uh, and this is one of the, uh, uh,
themes of the,
uh,
second section of the poem
where a odd and specifically,
uh, describes this painting. He says,
embroils ICARUS for
instance. Uh, and you know,
this is a poetry in which the poet
says, for instance, just as a,
um, uh, more might've said, however,
how everything turns away quite
leisurely from the disaster. And he's,
he's talking about a shepherd
who's looking up to the sky.
He's talking, uh, about, uh, the Plowman,
uh, who, uh, has his
back turned to, uh, um,
the fall. Uh, and, and where is it?
It's hard probably for you to see,
but it's hard to find in any case because
this dramatic event that is the center
of broils pictures,
in fact,
these bare legs disappearing
into the sea as the, uh,
uh, overreaching son of Daedalus
plunges into the water, uh,
not at all. Uh, in the
center of the picture,
how everything turns away
a lot and observes quite
leisurely from the disaster.
The Plowman may have heard the splash,
the forsaken cry,
but for him it was not an important
failure. He's not concerned with,
uh, flying to or beyond the son. For him,
the son merely shines it. It, uh, uh, uh,
helps him cultivate the land,
the sun shone of necessity as
it had to on the white legs,
disappearing into the green water,
the white legs disappearing into the green
water and the expensive delicate ship
that must've seen something amazing.
A boy falling out of the sky had
somewhere to get to and sailed calmly on,
well here,
uh,
odd and wasn't thinking about Hart Crane,
but he might've been a,
it's almost as if this,
uh,
figure has leaped off
the back of the boat. Uh,
as crane did, uh, he is,
however, thinking I suppose,
uh, about Romanticism in
general and its ambitions,
uh, here the sun shines as it had to, uh,
what it illuminates our white legs.
There's a kind of objectivity in
that there's a kind of naturalism,
uh, it shines on green water. Uh,
it's as if from a certain perspective,
from the perspective of aesthetic form,
these elements of the picture are,
uh, merely elements of a picture,
uh, colors, uh, uh,
which have meaning, uh,
as they are placed in a
system of relationships and
the system of perspectives.
Well, there's a great deal
more to be said about this, uh,
uh, painting. Um, I think, um,
one, uh, idea that, uh,
is worth emphasizing, uh, is the, uh, uh,
way in which the plow men,
uh,
in Auden's account as in
goals, uh, painting, uh,
has prominence, uh, has a greater
prominence than the, uh, uh,
heroic,
a romantic figure plunging into the sea.
The Plowman is going about
his ordinary daily work.
And as he turns these furrows,
we are reminded as odd and surely was
reminded of the ancient classical,
uh, uh, connection between verse, uh,
meaning the turning, uh,
of, um, in Latin, uh,
from one line to another. And
the, uh, uh, uh, shaping, uh,
action of the plow that,
uh,
creates these furrows in the earth,
committing the poet as he identifies
with the plowman to a kind of poetry of
craft and of the earth that involves,
in a sense,
turning away from a disaster.
Well,
uh,
this poem was written
in Europe. Uh, it is,
um, a, um, a poem that
Auden. Um, let me find this picture here,
uh, with which Auden in a
sense turns his back on,
uh, Europe and for the
moment at least the, uh, uh,
imminent world war,
he comes to the United States,
he immigrates to the United
States, uh, in January,
uh, 1939, um, this, uh,
personal, uh, uh, turning point, uh,
in a poetic career, um, uh,
comes at a moment when, um, uh,
the world is about to be split in war.
Uh,
it also, um, uh, comes a,
at a significant moment
in literary history, uh,
when Yeats dies.
And Auden recognizes this occasion as,
as a moment to
celebrate the poet, uh, uh, contemplate
the achievement in modern poetry
that he represents Yates, uh, and,
uh, in a sense, um, um,
provide a kind of a epitaph for, um, uh,
poetry now, uh, in the past, uh,
in behind us that positions on a,
in the present.
Let's look at the, the view of, um, uh,
Yates and of Yates is
poetry that emerges here.
Uh, the, um,
the poem extends the questions of
Music Day. Boats are by asking,
uh, not so much. What is arts
relation to suffering as,
what is the place of art
in society generally,
or poetry in particular?
Uh,
Arden begins, he disappeared in the
dead of winter. The bricks were frozen.
The airport's almost
deserted and snow disfigured.
The public statues,
the mercury sank in the
mouth of the dying day. Oh,
all the instruments agree.
The day of his death was a dark cold day.
Uh, there's, there's
a, a sense as odd and,
uh, elaborates these ideas that, um, um,
mmm,
well,
the natural sciences here mocking the,
a pathetic fallacy that all nature
should more when the poet dies,
uh, and reflect, uh, the, uh, um,
grief of this, uh, event, uh,
he's saying is it was a cold day and we
had instruments to measure it and that's
what it,
it was kind of a factual way.
Uh, he continues, Arden does.
Um,
uh,
now he Yates is scattered among a
hundred cities and wholly given over to
unfamiliar affections.
Uh,
the words of a dead man are
modified in the guts of the living.
Yates is passed on to us. Uh, and yet
to whom is he passed on?
What difference does he make?
Uh,
odd and doesn't want us to,
uh,
make the mistake to a thinking that Yates
is too central figure that he matters
too much. But in the importance
and noise of tomorrow,
he continues when the brokers are roaring
like beasts on the floor of the Boris
and the poor have the sufferings to which
they are fairly accustomed in each and
the sell of himself as almost
convinced of his freedom.
A few thousand,
we'll think of this day as one thinks of
the day when one did something slightly
unusual.
This is,
this is a attempt to, in some
sense, uh, plays poetry. Uh,
realistically, uh, in culture. Uh,
it doesn't matter to the brokers worrying
like beasts on the floor of the Boris.
Uh,
it doesn't matter to the poor who have
their suffering to which they're fairly
accustomed manner as well,
perhaps to a few thousand people,
not a negligible number. Uh,
but not a large one either.
There's a kind of a modesty,
a in Odense claims for Yates
for poetry. Uh, you could,
you could contrast pound at the same time.
Uh,
is this poem is written a broadcasting
his ideas on fascist radio.
Uh, or you could think about, um, uh,
Stevens at the same
time dreaming up a poem.
He will call notes towards the supreme
fiction. This is a rather different, uh,
claim for what poetry might do.
Uh,
it, uh, returns to a theme
of the wasteland somehow. Uh,
the world that Auden,
um,
is describing is one in which we are
each imprisoned in the cell of ourselves.
Uh, recalling the, the
locked chambers, uh, of,
um, uh, Elliot's poem. Um,
in the second section,
Auden moves to address Yates directly.
Uh, now, uh,
Yates is in a sense
claimed for us. Uh, his,
his difference, uh,
the, the, uh, that Hick,
uh, powers of language,
the visionary ambition,
uh, the, uh, a cult learning,
uh, all of that, uh,
that would distinguish and
separate him from us, uh, is, um,
um, put aside. And, uh,
what he shares with us,
uh, is, um, emphasized.
You were silly,
like us silly.
Your gift survived at all.
It had to survive a lot.
It had to survive the parish
of rich women who doted on him,
uh,
his own physical decay himself.
Arden says Mad Ireland
hurt you into poetry.
Now Ireland has her madness and her,
whether still you did not affect it,
uh, you did not affect it because
you are a man and only a man.
In fact,
poetry makes nothing happen.
This is a, um, hmm.
One of the most quoted
sentences in modern poetry.
Poetry makes nothing happen. Uh, it, uh,
is almost always quoted.
However, out of context,
it is part of a long sentence. Uh, it,
it comes first as a, as a,
uh, uh, qualification on,
on what Yates and the difference
Yates has made in the world
pod and saying in a sense, no, you,
you haven't made a difference, uh,
for poetry makes nothing happen.
Uh, but the poem continues.
Then the sentence continues.
Uh,
Auden says colon,
it survives poetry makes nothing happen.
It's survives
where it's survives.
In the valley of it's saying where
executives would never want to tamper.
It flows south from ranches of
isolation and the busy griefs,
raw towns that we believe in.
Diane,
it survives a way of happening.
A mouth
poetry. It doesn't make
things happen. What it does,
it has a different kind of action.
It's survives.
It lasts. A, how does it
last? Where does it lasts?
It lasts in the valley of it's saying a
kind of imaginary landscape or kind of
world that is created through speech here.
Uh,
the Valley of its saying, uh,
perhaps a rich place to live,
but also a space that evokes
a kind of absence or hollow,
right. Uh, or we're kind of
opening, uh, perhaps, um,
or gap, uh, as odd and develops this idea.
Uh, the, uh, um, uh,
poetry becomes what he calls,
um,
a way of happening,
a mouth.
And then that valley is
refigured as a mouth, uh,
and open mouth, I'm sure a mouth
open, uh, where words are coming out,
uh, where, uh, more words will, uh,
follow and flow like a kind of river,
uh, poetry in that sense. It
doesn't make anything happen.
It is rather a way of happening.
Uh,
that is a kind of method or model,
a path or discipline, uh, way.
Uh,
not a deed a,
but something more like the symbol of
the deed or the figure of a kind of
potential action and nothing
that is somehow something to,
uh, again, uh, I think, um, uh,
an image implying an open
mouth, uh, that is, uh,
the mouth of a river, the mouth
of a poet, uh, through which, uh,
language flows.
Then the poem moves into, um, I think, uh,
a kind of illustration of the kind
of action that poetry engages in.
Uh,
and that comes with the movement
into the ceremonial quite trains,
uh, in, uh, I am Vick,
uh, uh, Ted Transmitter,
essentially. What does that,
what it is? Well, uh, uh, it's,
it's definitely a tet
tram runner. Um, the, um,
uh, rhyme mentors, uh,
the rhythms of the palm up to now
a give way to a kind of ceremonial,
a lyric language, uh, here, uh,
poetry is identified with
praise and with prayer.
Uh,
the poem gives us a kind of performative
language of human ceremony that,
uh, honors, uh, Yates that, uh, uh,
lays him to rest, uh, and yet, uh,
also absorbs and affirms
the power of poetry,
uh, that was, um, in him earth.
Receive an honored guest.
William Yeats is laid to rest.
Let the Irish vessel
lie empty of its poetry.
Oh, hadn't goes on to,
uh, uh, describe the, uh,
uh, way that, um, time
we'll honor poetry and we'll honor Yates,
uh,
that time. Uh, we'll even,
he says,
Auden does forgive Yeates for
the right wing politics that,
uh, Yates is a later career
is marked by and that,
uh, Auden, uh, separates
himself from and, uh, uh,
needs to come to terms with in this poem,
he says a time that with
this strange excuse,
pardon Kipling and his views and
we'll pardon Paul Claudel, uh, uh,
Kipling for his imperial
jingoism, uh, Cadel for his, uh,
you know, Prodo Fascist,
uh, uh, uh, ideas,
pardons Yates also for writing. Well, uh,
odd. And looking back on this
poem, uh, would ask himself,
how could I possibly presume to, um, uh,
judge Yates and forgive him
morally for his politics?
Uh, and, uh, struck these, uh, uh,
condescending lines from his poem
so you won't find them
in the collected pumps,
but you will find the powerful lines that,
uh,
proceed from them in the
nightmare of the dark.
All the dogs of Europe bark
and the living nations wait,
each sequestered in it's hate.
Intellectual disgraced stares from
every human face in the seeds of pity.
Lie locked frozen in each eye.
What does the poet do in this condition?
Follow poet.
Follow right to the bottom of the night.
Poet descends and descends into night,
uh,
uh, a night that is a, um,
this nightmare in which, uh, uh, Europe
barks ready to attack itself
with your unconstrained voice.
Still persuade us to rejoice
with the farming of a verse.
And remember the plowman now
as a figure for the poet.
Make a vineyard of the curse.
Sing of human unsuccess in a rapture of
distress in the deserts of the heart.
Let the healing fountains start
in the prison of his days,
teach the free man how to praise.
This is what poetry can
offer. Uh, these, uh, uh,
it can offer a lesson in how to praise.
This is not a, this is not
making something happen, uh,
politically in the world,
perhaps, uh, but it's making
something happen in the heart. Uh,
and, uh, perhaps within
the eye of each of us,
uh, who, uh, look, uh, locked and, uh,
staring with our pity,
uh, frozen there, uh,
poetry would, um, uh,
would be a kind of farming in the
desert of the heart that would,
um, uh, break open a that
which is locked there, uh,
and, uh, free feeling. Uh, it's a, uh,
it's a powerful and very traditional
a claim for what poems can do.
Uh, and, uh, you know, in, in
talking about the wasteland, I,
I stressed,
uh,
the ways in which Elliot
sought a language of,
of public ritual that might, um, uh,
join people, uh, separated
in the cells of themselves.
Here Auden is working through the same
ideas and providing a kind of model for
how that might work.
Uh,
let me, uh, turn ahead with
you to, uh, another, uh,
great poem from this period.
Uh, in memory of Sigmund Freud.
Uh, fried, uh,
is a kind of plowman. Uh, he is, uh,
another model for the poet
for Auden. Uh, and this poem,
uh,
proposes still other ways to understand,
poetry's relation to suffering a
represented here by Freud's humanistic
therapeutic technique.
Yeah.
Uh,
what sort of hero is Freud a and calls
him and important Jew who died in exile?
Uh, it's significant that
he has called that by, uh,
on, uh, at this moment. Uh, if you,
if you look for the figure of the Jew
in Garanti and Eliot's early palm,
you'll see that, uh, the, uh, uh,
figure is not dignified
with the capital j. Uh,
antisemitism is a, uh,
uh, crisis in Europe. Uh,
and it's certainly a
pervasive current, uh, in, uh,
modern poetry, whether, uh,
it is actually a theme or
Motif as it appears in Elliot,
or a pound or a simply a, uh, um,
kind of, uh, uh,
voluble prejudice as you would find
it in Williams. His letters, uh,
antisemitism is, is, uh,
powerful. Uh, and here, uh,
Aaden is identifying himself with
Freud as a Jew and as a Jew in exile.
Uh, and, uh,
it seems as though Freud in this
way represents a figure for people,
uh,
who are in some sense
extracted from the nation,
uh, and, uh, who are international
in their perspective.
Uh,
and Auden himself is writing in
America from a similar point of view.
Um,
as in the Yates allergy.
Auden is reluctant to single
fried out when, uh, as he says,
death is so common and
suffering is so common.
But Freud's point of view for Auden,
uh,
is powerful and valuable precisely because
it emphasizes the common placeness of
human suffering. Uh, its ubiquity,
uh,
um,
he's praised, uh, Freud is,
uh, as the palm a unfolds,
uh,
specifically for the ways in
which he responds to suffering.
Um, his, uh, uh, how does
he, how does he do it?
Well,
uh, around line 28 or so, on
page eight of eight Oh four,
mmm
Oh, Adam says all that he did
was to remember like the old,
and be honest, like
children. He wasn't clever
at all.
He was silly like us.
He merely told the unhappy present to
recite the past like a poetry lesson
till sooner or later it faltered at the
line where long ago the accusations had
begun and suddenly new by whom it had
been judged how rich life had been and how
silly. There's that word again and
was life forgiven in more humble,
no wonder the ancient cultures of
conceit in his technique of unsettlement,
that's what he hadn't called
Freud's therapeutic technique,
the talking cure.
It's a technique of unsettlement
the ancient cultures of conceits
seeing it, the fall of princes,
the collapse of their lucrative
patterns of frustration.
If he had succeeded Freud, why the
generalized life would become impossible.
The monolith of state be broken and
prevented the cooperation of Avengers.
Of course,
they called on God,
his Freud's detractors,
but he went his way like the poet who
follows right to the bottom of the night
down among the loss. People like
Dante down to the stinking fast,
where the injured lead the
ugly life of the rejected
and showed us what evil is, not as we
thought deeds that must be punished,
but our lack of faith are dishonest.
Mood of denial.
The king Coupa since of the oppressor,
odd emphasizes,
ah,
okay.
Freud's, uh, um, um,
literary dimensions, uh, uh,
the talking cure, uh, is,
is like a poetry lesson. Uh, it,
it puts faith in speech and
the powers of true speech to,
uh,
correct and reshape and heal human life.
Uh,
it is a technique of unsettlement that
is a threat to princess all worldly
authority because it questions authority,
uh,
and empowers the individual speaker
to take life into his hands,
uh, like Dante or like
pounds Ulysses and Canto one,
uh, uh, like the poet, uh,
in, uh, the end of, of, uh,
the eights elegy. Uh,
Freud in Auden's poem,
uh, goes down among the last people, uh,
goes into the stinking fos,
which is a powerful word.
It's a word that appears in Canto.
Yeah.
Uh, where are you list these,
uh, uh, pounds Ulysses goes to,
to seek Tyree cs a foss,
it's an Anglo Saxon word.
Uh, it reaches back in that
sense and cultural history, uh,
to suggest, um, you know, that
are our present mystery. Uh,
excuse me. Our present misery is, um, uh,
one with continuous with that of the past.
Uh,
and yet history is something
here that can be intervened in,
in,
uh,
an individual way through the kind of a
true speech that a Auden celebrates in
Freud, uh, and that he
aspires to in poetry,
uh, as, uh,
the LG builds towards its conclusion.
Yeah.
Uh,
on page eight Oh six,
again, the night appears, uh,
Freud would have us remember most of all
to be in the ass dick over the night.
And it's lost people ourselves,
not only for the sense of wonder
that it alone has to offer night the
unconscious,
but also because it needs our love
for,
with sad eyes.
It's delectable creatures look up and
beg us dumb Lee to ask them to follow.
That is all the properties
here of the unconscious who,
uh, that are identified at
the same time, uh, with, uh,
all those who are lost in
society, uh, and need to be, uh,
represented, uh, and
claimed they are like Freud,
a exiles who long for the
future that lies in our power.
Again, power of speech. Uh,
they too would rejoice if allowed to
serve enlightenment like him, like Freud.
Uh,
even to bear our cry of Judas as he
did in all must bear who serve it.
Uh, Freud here, uh, is uh, uh,
uh, an exile and he brings insight, uh,
but he also brings love.
Uh,
Arden is imagining a kind of
general state of homelessness, uh,
which Freud's technique of unsettlement,
uh, isn't meant to redress,
but rather to recognize and accept
and help us adjust to and live in.
Uh, Arden's own technique here, uh,
is, um, uh, I, uh,
well his verse form is
a simple syllable count.
11 syllables, 11 syllables,
nine syllables, 10.
The normative 10 syllable line comes
last and fourth and gives a kind of
resolution to each quad train.
Uh,
this a simple pattern.
Again,
accommodates and promotes
a kind of pro speech,
a kind of ordinariness that identifies
Freud's work and the poet's work with a
kind of ordinary ongoing
work, uh, and, uh,
that accommodates rationality
and irrational voice,
uh, as, uh, uh, uh, odd.
And we'll describe Freud's as being,
and yet also accommodates
feeling at the same time.
Uh,
accommodates love.
One rational voice is dumb.
Freud's,
he's silent in over a grave,
his grave to household of impulse.
Morin's one dearly loved
because he understood
how to love our impulses,
sad as Erath builder of cities
and weeping in our kick Aphrodite.
Uh, it's, uh, uh, eventually a, a,
a, a, a powerful, uh, uh, moving, uh,
conclusion arrows and Aphrodite
have lost their champion.
Um, I'm gonna, uh, conclude, uh, by, uh,
commenting very quickly since
we're almost out of time. Um, uh,
on one last poem, uh, arguably
Auden's, uh, greatest, uh,
in praise of limestone,
a poem written
from the perspective of the postwar,
uh, in the United States, uh, but,
uh, about, um,
a kind of imaginary landscape
that combines elements of, uh,
his childhood, uh, landscape in
northern England. Uh, and the,
uh, Italian landscape, uh,
where, uh, he returned, uh,
in the postwar period, uh, and, um, uh,
became increasingly, uh, attached
to, uh, it is a kind of, uh,
allegorical, uh, space. Uh,
and it represents a kind
of home, I suppose for, uh,
the homeless for, uh, uh,
we, the inconstant ones,
uh, as he describes us. Uh,
it is this limestone landscapes
something to be praised.
And it is a poem of praise. Uh, it is, um,
uh,
an image of the world
without another transcendental
world beyond or behind it,
uh, to be in the world as
described in this poem, uh,
is to be in an entirely earthly realm.
And again,
you might think of the Plowman,
uh, turning away from, uh, the, uh,
uh, overreach or, uh,
who tried to fly to the sky
and turns rather to, uh,
the earth. Uh, it is, uh,
a landscape like that of
Steven's in Sunday morning.
Uh, it is, uh, uh, a landscape, um,
that Arden can only describe
as a kind of imaginary place,
uh, as a, uh, through
counterfactual, uh, statements. Uh,
it is, uh, uh, well,
uh, porous. It's rich.
It's fertile. Uh, it's moderate. Uh,
it is not a place of extremes and,
uh,
hermits and Caesar's, they don't
belong here. They go elsewhere.
Uh, it, it's rather, uh, a, uh, uh,
a place in which ordinary
life and ordinary people, uh,
might live. Uh, the very
end of the poem, uh,
is extremely powerful because it looks
towards a kind of a redeemed human life,
sees it in this landscape,
uh, and yet represents it. Uh,
in the conditional, uh, Auden says
a,
insofar as this is an eight oh eight w
in so far as we have to look forward to
death as a fact,
something he will never let us forget.
No doubt we are right.
But if sins can be forgiven,
if bodies rise from the dead,
and you note the
conditional in both phrases,
these modifications of matter
into innocent athletes,
the people that he people's
this landscaped with and
just stipulating fountains
made solely for pleasure,
make a further point.
The blessing will not care what angle
they are regarded from having nothing to
hide deer.
And now he speaks to a beloved dear.
I know nothing of either.
What?
Uh, what that is, what it would mean to
be blessed or to have nothing to hide.
I know nothing of either of those things,
but when I try to imagine a faultless
love or the life to come when I hear is
the murmur of underground streams,
what I see is a limestone landscape,
a landscape that is Auden's
version of an earthly paradise. Uh,
our only image of these
ultimate, uh, uh, promises,
uh, ardent manages somehow here to, uh,
make us see and feel what the
life to come might be like,
what it might be like to be blessed while
still acknowledging that we can only
live in and be in and speaking,
uh, the world before us.
Uh,
which is the one that Auden remains
throughout his poetry dedicated to,
well,
uh,
we'll go on to a poet closely,
identified with Auden,
uh,
Elizabeth Bishop on Wednesday.